on computer file we just love
provocative and mysterious titles and
carrying on from the last time we spoke
let's say this is going to be a chat
about what came to be called the uncle
problem universal computer language I
think it stands for it was more specific
than just any old computer language it
was is there a unique intermediate
language which would suit everybody you
know not as high as C even and not quite
down at the absolute binary level but
more like a sort of absolutely Universal
assembler a pseudo assembler it it's not
really Hardware implemented on any
machine but it's it's one that we can
all work with and every compiler in the
whole world all they would have to do is
produce the uncle language if we can
only agree what it is and then every
system could talk to every other system
at this agreed low level well as you can
imagine it doesn't work like that it
very soon became obvious that yes this
business of putting a level in there and
saying we'll all compile to intermediate
code is fine but when you start looking
at what facilities it should have what
facilities he shouldn't have your rep
against the fact that computer hardware
designers like to do things their own
way I mean numbers of registers might be
16 might be fewer that's no big deal
some of them have ranged those registers
in a formal or informal stack others
don't should we always assume that we
have stack capabilities and I think if
somebody pointed out to me I think Ron
Ron not who originally created these
notes he said the thing in the end that
kills you is that they all do
input-output differently there's almost
no agreement about how you do i/o so
fairly soon the idea of finding one
unique into me
language had to be forgotten about but
the idea of different intermediate
languages at different levels of
sophistication really did gain traction
in the 1980s we mentioned that Steve
Bourne had his Zed code as part of his
uncle 68 project way back in the early
eighties little bit later on I think it
was in the eighties many of you will
know this one better James Gosling
developed the language of Java in which
he decided that pointers were dangerous
and should be hidden but therein lies
another story but the big thing that
James made a feature of was to say I
want my Java systems to compile down to
what he called byte code in other words
it was a sort of pseudo assembler with
really like single byte op codes like a
and Zed and whatever and yes byte code
became flavor the month we all go down
to byte code well then what do you do
well you've got choices you could either
write an interpreter for byte code which
will be easy to change it will be a
little slow a bit big if you're really
passionately about having the ultimate
super fast and efficient binary you can
always compile a byte code get it
smaller and all that so you had options
but the idea was that yes you would have
an intermediate code even so it's not a
one-size-fits-all there's still it was
ideal for what James wanted to do but
its extensibility to be a universal
panacea not so you see let me give you
another good example of why some people
might want to move the semantic barrier
a bit higher I mean byte code is fairly
low-level what about if we move it up so
we're getting more airy-fairy
heaven knows might encounter Haskell way
up there somewhere
classic example of course is a
development of C++ and as many of you
know as its name implies it goes beyond
see it adds classes and all sorts of
other features to Z and the idea of from
be honest rooster
the inventor was that to get something
going in the first instance at least he
would have cost you the obvious thing he
his compiler would compile a C++ down to
C and then you could put it just through
an older mercy compiler from the back
end so you see his uncle is it's a much
higher level of sophistication than
pseudo assembler type bytecode level and
you might say oh well that's great I
mean it's obviously Suit C++ to do that
yes it did but there are big problems
with this approach
once you broadcast the fact that
actually C++ your Marquand compiler is
producing C under the hood you will have
the devil's own job in convincing
benevolent hackers who think they can
generate better C code than be honest
rooster up cat getting in behind the
scenes and messing about with the way he
does classes for example so I suppose
what I'm saying more generally about
this is that very often you will have a
very good solution for language system
to establish a bridgehead and to get
something working but in the longer run
you might want a more direct version
that isn't is prone to hacker intrusion
gross abuse or just things going a bit
wrong because of the nature of the
intermediate language being so rich and
having a mind of its own now you myself
bats can't be an issue can it yes it can
because this whole question of level of
your intermediate code this thing gets
me there why do I need to go direct let
me give you another example
not C++ this time another well-known
example for many of you is PDF it's been
so well-established for so long now
since 1989
that many of you using it will not know
that in the early days it came off the
back of Adobe's very successful language
called PostScript and PostScript was
there as you know the universal graphics
language
it drove laser printers it grow whatever
is a wonderful achievement in order to
get a PDF the way you did it originally
was you compile your PostScript with
Anand o be provided utility called
distiller but the problem was in many
ways it was very graphically
sophisticated but it was chewing
complete you could do anything in this
and indeed I often thought well the next
program I wrote in PostScript before I
do any typesetting as ordered by the
customer I will get my program to solve
a commands function first can you
imagine the delay I'm sorry I'm going to
compute a command 3-1 before I turn my
attention to doing your miserable little
piece of typesetting but in principle
you could have done that as long as it
didn't run out of memory but you know
I'm just saying this to make a silly
point that that's perfectly doable you
sometimes found that your PDF produced
out of compiling PostScript interstella
yards bigger than the input not very
often but sometimes so there again you
say in order to stop abuse and to point
the way to the future and they'll be
very quickly saying what we must do for
those that don't know about those could
have no need for it is to give a direct
route to PDF and they called it PDF
writer back in the early days and then
of course people don't want it to be
bound into Adobe quite rightly said
fabulous what we need to do is to
replicate something of what distiller
does will write utilities with names
like PS to PDF which you'll typically
find in PostScript offerings on Linux
and all this kind of stuff but it makes
the point that very often that
directness of approach gives you a good
result
and stops people messing about under the
hood and doing things which are
ridiculous and expensive if you start
saying no from now on it's much quicker
to go direct we know how to do it let's
do it let's keep it clean so that is I
guess I think a feature still I keep
reading stories of people using
intermediate codes for compiling
programming languages who suddenly say
well 20 years down the line we think
intermediate codes are bad it's far
better to do it direct in some other way
and all you can say out of this is that
every time you get into porting software
you learn something every time about the
pros and cons of having an intermediate
representation or do you jump over it
and go direct there is no universal
right answer the more you look at the
scene at the moment about program
language implementation the more you
realize that a huge number of the
offerings out there might look to you
like straightforward point-to-point
compilers you know I'm running on a
whatever I'm running on I'm running on
an ARM chip it's all self hosted on the
ARM chip it compiles arm code for
further use on further ARM chips it
doesn't do anything else not true if you
look under the hood of GCC of course
Stallman and the no effort did such a
wonderful job in creating for us a new
version of CC when you look in there at
the possible backends for different
architectures you realize it's really a
cross compilation system you can compile
from anything to anything now other
people other than the new effort got
there eventually and realized the same
thing I mean I think Microsoft in the
mid 80s did actually had the nerve to
develop something but I think they
called intermediate language I don't
know where the Microsoft did try and
actually copyright the phrase
intermediate language but it's part of
the same mindset it's not just them that
Apple and Steve Joe
was always used to have it may have
existed but it was done by a bunch of no
hope Asst and until we discovered it
packaged it marketed and put it for you
you might as well think it never existed
and that was jobs through and through
but maybe all big computer companies
have a little bit of this inside them it
didn't really exist in a usable way
until we discovered it if I have the
token so let's bring back friendly Steve
so we've now got a token and we what
we're going to say is it unless I've got
the token I cannot access it but
delivers back the integer result in its
local variable for to declares for
itself for holding the answer and
eventually of course look it's going to
return